hey julia how are you so nice to meet
you
nice to meet you i have to tell you i'm
such a fan of you
and your family the show is so good even
after the first episode i was like
yep i'm hooked um oh my goodness thank
you
no it's really good did you ever have
any initial reaction of
maybe feeling like you didn't want the
world in to see your life in such an
intimate way
oh yes i mean it's something that
honestly i still feel right now i feel
i mean it is fine you know you're
basically
exposing yourself and being like hey
here i am come judge me
right which is a bit frightening
especially with my children
um but i felt that i had a reason
and a purpose and that it was very
critical for me
to share my story with the world at this
particular moment of time when i think
women i want women to really go for it
it's
our i really feel it's our turn and so
yeah
i felt that it was a story that needed
to be told and
yeah it's scary what are you gonna say
yeah
but it's so fascinating and i feel like
i learned a lot while watching
your show as well you know you speak
very openly about leaving your ultra
orthodox jewish community to start this
new life
what was that moment when you knew that
that life wasn't for you anymore
well honestly it wasn't a moment it was
pretty much an
eight-year experience to get me from
i'm not happy to i'm walking out the
door to
actually walking out the door um but
the reality is that that story is so
long i wrote a book it's called um
brazen and believe it or not
this is going to sound hilarious but
yeah originally when i handed it in it's
being published by crown penguin random
house
when i handed it in it was 1740 pages
so it is it is now a delightful
450 some odd pages but the point being
that it's a
very very complex story to be told
because it's not like
all of a sudden you wake up in the
morning you're like okay i'm out first i
had to
realize and give myself permission to
acknowledge that i wasn't happy
then i had to educate myself and i
became a veracious reader and i
literally taught myself everything
because i had had no education
and then i had to figure out a way to
make money and then
i had to have that impetus to actually
walk out the door and that impetus was
my daughter miriam
if it wasn't for her i never would have
left she
and what was it about her that that that
was that moment for you or not moment
but just that was the the
that final that was the last that was
the final straw right so
that moment was i mean she is a
brilliant young woman
she uh is now going into
uh her senior in stanford university if
i'm not mistaken she was the youngest
teacher stanford university ever had
because as a freshman she taught a class
in augmented reality
so here is a kid who had i not left
would be
married with probably baby number two on
the way
in the kitchen in muncie muir here she
is she's a proud bisexual with an
amazing
um you know relationship that she has
with this fantastic woman that i'm not
supposed to say more about so i won't
um but uh you know and she is
sharing her brilliance with the world
and i saw them
trying to push her down and molt her
into that
silent obedient disappearing woman
and i couldn't let them do it to her um
you know you are the ceo of elite world
group did you
have any idea that when you left that
old life that your career would take off
in the way that it has of course i had
no idea where i would end up but all i
knew is that i had to succeed
it was literally when you get to that
point of misery and desperation
it's it's really life or death and so it
didn't
occur to me that i would fail because
failure would mean i'd have to go back
and going back was death so there was no
failure there was no
option for failure genuinely um you know
there's so many
fantastic moments in this series but
definitely the beginning i love how you
admit the first time that you saw an
r-rated series with sex in the city at
the age of 38.
so how did those women in their lives
affect you
i mean you have to realize that i grew
up basically what i would say is the
1800s right
and to be very clear there isn't this
has nothing to do with judaism this has
nothing to do with my community
this is fundamentalism and it exists in
hundreds of communities around the world
as we all know
governments countries religions you name
it there are many places that have those
fundamentalist aspects
so that's what this is about i have
nothing against my community
i learned so many beautiful things
charity
kindness um you know community
taking care of one another my brother
died when he was five years old
and you should have seen how the
community came together and took care of
each other took care of us it was
very beautiful so this has nothing to do
with that this has to do
with the fact that as a woman in my
world your only purpose
is to serve an end of story and
that that part i couldn't
stand anymore because i had all of this
inside of me i had
so much that i wanted to show with the
world and share with the world
and create and that wasn't my purpose my
purpose
was to be obedient to my husband and to
raise holy daughters who would be
obedient to their husbands
and holy sons who would become rabbis
that was my only purpose in life
well i thank you so much for sharing
your story i can't wait for everyone to
see this show it's so
entertaining and honestly i love your
kids you did a really good job with them